this is the Savannah River I like the
bridge I'm a sucker for bridges a year
ago I was in this park with the Yeti now
I'm alone and I miss her and I'm sad is
that what divorce would be like would
divorce be like being in Savannah
Georgia all the time for the rest of my
life with no Yeti I'm in the airport of
Savannah Georgia I have to record this
all in one take and I'll tell you why I
have to record it all in one take it's
because I left my power charger for my
computer at home so I only have 23
minutes of power left and it's looking
increasingly like I'm not going to get
back to New York by midnight Hank I'm in
a good news/bad news situation the bad
news I arrived at the airport four hours
early but I won't be able to leave until
my regular flight leaves because there's
no earlier flights the good news this
game seems to be called nerdfighters
that's my favorite kind of fighters
thank you I want to be from America or
Japan or Sweden answer Sweden I would
like to be this Viking nerd killer
now I shall kill nerds I'm scared I'm
scared I got a trumpet I got a trap the
camera I got to go I got to go bye
I don't like to travel okay we're going
to walk through the airport and see if
we can find anything funny the word
Choate is funny because this airport
services Hilton Head South Carolina
there are a lot of golfers here they're
not wearing golf shoes but you can tell
that they're golfers you want to see
wait golfer golfer golfer golfers baby
golfer golfer
this makes things easier a word of
parting my chin is prepared